at the end of episode one we were
ambushed by a Voort watchdog of the
boreal valley and what follows is a
really incredible boss fight such a huge
part of it for me was the music in phase
two the boss becomes enraged and your
heart rate steps it up and the music
just matches it all the entire time
bought is now tried a knight of the
boreal valley every outrider night one
day devolves into a beast constantly
hounded by pontiff Sullivan's black eyes
the black eye ring reads Knight Superion
to the black orb are lured into the
paddles of death transformed into
frenzied beasts
no wonder the pontiff only provides
these rings to those dispatched to
foreign lands oh this is phase two
gonna blame that loss on the fact that I
switched the torch accidentally I just
matched the d-pad badly the next five
went much more smoothly gotta say these
first two boss fights have been on blood
bonds level of boss fights seriously
they're really great although I do hope
that they give the bosses more hit
points in the final build
I think everyone beat it a bit too
easily board was guarding Lorex only
exit and since he's referred to as
watchdog and outrider
night it's logical that he exists to
stop people particularly an undead
perhaps reaching that valley and leaving
lothric we can see some icy mountains
and castles and valleys in the distance
after all and that's where we're headed
cuz look who's back
I'm seeing a pattern here the gargoyles
of Dark Souls 1 were demons that
appeared all over anor londo responding
to a ring of light and pulling the
undead from the decrepit undead lands to
the city of the Lord's and on the flip
side the gargoyles of Dark Souls 3 see a
character raising a ringed banner of
lothric and Carrie Aaron kindled down
off the high wall to the decrepit undead
settlement to hunt down the lords that
Emma said fled lothric my point is that
it's another example of antithesis that
I've described in other videos where
core tropes of the series aren't really
being changed they're being flipped ad
travelling down instead of up to that
list undo my shackles
Oh
oh then it's true a champion of ash as I
live and breathe to be in your presence
is a great honor
I am Knoll of Londo a pilgrim as you can
see only somehow I failed to die as was
ordained well perhaps my calling lies
elsewhere
say champion of ash how does the idea of
taking me into your service strike you I
was once a sorcerer
surely I can be of use oh I am honored
truly I should be dead yet you who have
granted me purpose and new I yo love
Londo do solemnly swear myself to you
y'all will now appear at our Firelink
shrine but his fellow pilgrims all died
reaching for lothric and if they were
prophesized to die on this journey then
why did they come going back to our
shrine for a moment we meet this guy hmm
I'm kindled are we
and fast on the trail of the Lord's
absconded then these red eyes are for
you
use them to pillage embers and briefly
heighten your strength for your duty
what else are on Kindle - is good for oh
and I didn't tell you guys this last
episode but back in lothric a meta thief
named grey rat ah even OG lair are you
know no you're from far away and judging
by the Bell
you must be some of that and Kingdom ash
long story short he asks you to give a
ring to a woman named Loretta someone
he's presumably close to do your part
and I'll do mine
the undead settlement is full of Thieves
like gray rat who climb all over
buildings and hang from roofs and damn
good professionals at ambushing you I
thought I was being careful when I
explored this dark building and then
afterwards I found gray rats
Lauretta heaven--the she was already
dead thank you
I'm not surprised though almost a relief
really after dramatically falling to the
ground
I love the new emotes by the way I
reloaded the area and I realized that
you can send gray rat on a thieving
quest to get some new loot in his
inventory and when he returns he sells
awesome weapons like the pontiff curved
sword and other things like this by
hander for example but back to the
settlement this is an area of wood fire
worship and the burning imprisonment
restrainment and torture of hollows and
a common problem in souls universes is
actually what to do with the overflow of
undead killing them is never permanent
so putting them in cages is a pretty
popular solution well a partial solution
from the workers attire we learned that
they're also working here to dissect and
bury undead although apparently the
ceremonial significance of such work is
forgotten this guy for example uses his
pot of undead remains as a weapon this
fight turned into a really cool moment
though where I quickly noticed a
remaining fire barrel and used it to my
advantage another exciting moment was in
the sewers with low health
no Estes and some rats in a tunnel I
can't believe it didn't attack at the
end there I got so lucky but this this
was probably the most terrifying moment
so about now you might be wondering
which tower is this episode titled
after its that one if you listened
carefully here you could hear the back
of a giant bowstring being released
there's a giant on the top of that tower
and he's firing arrows at us and now
that I've explored the majority of the
area I know exactly where it is
so it's time to get him to stop most of
you probably know this but characters
are one of the most important parts of
the series for me and the knight that we
meet in this tower along with the whole
experience within it is going to be a
memorable experience for a lot of us
hmm pardon me I was absorbed in thought
I am Zig that of Katarina to be honest
I'm in a bit of a pickle have you ever
walked near a white birch only to be
struck by a great arrow well if I'm not
mistaken they come from this tower
whoever it is I'm sure I can talk some
sense into them but I have to find a way
up and that's just the trouble
this lift only goes down you see and
well that doesn't get me anywhere hmm
who are you I help anytime
there is the white birch that
siegward was talking about this giant
will now only attack enemies whenever
you're near it
mmm-hmm did you hear that mmm
mmm-hmm oh don't disappear like that you
had me downright worried but thanks to
you an epiphany has struck me square in
the head
I've unraveled the riddle of this
inscrutable lift
on some days I begin to doubt myself I
went up the tower so I thought then
somehow ended up here I'm not exactly
sure what happened anyhow do you see
that that humongous beast I know
coward and I'll a steady hand but that
thing makes my skin crawl
now now think twice before you go down
that road
I could cry talking some sense into him
no I think not is far too overheated
I've got to use my head and think hmm
hmm in this moment I knew exactly what
to do it's the flip side of what
happened in lost izalith so long ago now
no you should have waited well it's too
late now
Isaac were the Knights of Catarina fight
by your side
ah that was quite a performance but you
mustn't get in over your head
we unpinned 'old must put our duties
first but for the moment we have a toast
to make to your Vera my sword and our
victory together long may the Sun Shine
well I'm going to have myself a little
nap the only thing to do really after a
nice toast even recording this narration
after playing watching it again just
makes me grin like an idiot this is
Sigma Y or siegward I suppose now a
character who featured in prepare to cry
so long ago which is the series that got
this channel off the ground the channel
that led to me being able to play the
game early and share it with you guys
and I don't know about you but it's
pretty special seeing this guy again and
I can't wait to see where his journey
ends up this time at the very least we
know that there is one amazing character
in this game right more familiar faces
are in episode 3 which is going to be
the final pre-released playthrough and
the one with the most significant law
implications that we've seen yet I'm
very confident I found some stuff that
was really hidden and if you're watching
all these spoilers it's stuff you
probably haven't seen yet so thank you
as always for watching and I hope you're
liking it